I love you too.
Did you mean it?
Of course, I meant it.
No.
No, you know what?
If I'm gonna feel guilty
about something,
I'm gonna feel guilty
about this.
$49.99?
Can we sell it that low?
We're all gonna die!
Please, save us
from destruction.
Thank you, Ganesh.
We're all gonna die!
Dear Allah,
in your infinite power
and compassion,
please save us
from destruction.
Try and slow your breathing.
I can't.
Stiles, look at me.
Look at me.
Stiles.
You love me.
You're such an idiot.
I love you too.
-Hey.
Thought I might
find you in here.
I just needed to process
the captain's news.
I feel so bad for him.
So, how you holdin' up?
I don't know.
I'm still in shock.
You?
I'm basically handling it
the way I dealt
with my dad leaving,
just repressing
the hell out of it.
So, a lot of change
around here, huh?
Hey, Jake,
the new captain's here.
There you are.
Are you hiding up here
from my friends?
No.
I like your friends.
Come on, Fab.
I haven't seen you
this nervous
since the last
Space X launch.
It's really upsetting
when they explode.
Well, why don't we just
hang out in here,
you and me?
Wait,
I am hooking up in here?
About ten minutes ago.
No, I didn't know
what to say.
Yes, I know.
Um, I don't know, Mom.
He's my best friend.
Yeah, he's great.
Yeah, I think I am.
I have to go. I will.
Listen, Jim…
Did you mean it?
Of course, I meant it.
I can't. I can't do this.
OK.
I understand.
I don't…
I don't want
to lose you again.
I know. I'm confused.
This is confusing me.
Ruby, don't look.